some breaking news in the world oh
sports concerns the vegas golden knights
multiple sources in canada has basically
been confirmed now the golden knights
have acquired injured star center jack
eichel and a 2023 third round pick from
the buffalo sabres 4 the two people you
just saw alex tuck who is injured right
now and peyton krebs they're heading to
buffalo
the sabers are also getting a first
round draft pick third in 2023 bottom
line it's it's alex tuck for jack eichel
who is jack eichel he's injured right
now he's one of the top players in the
league he had a big brouhaha with the
sabres that he wanted to leave town they
didn't want to let him go
this trade is not official from the team
yet but it basically is essentially
everybody's reporting it uh so jack
eichel would when he's healthy
fit on the first line wow as a top
center which the golden knights have
needed for a long long time but he has
to have this neck surgery yeah didn't
you say it's a disc issue he has a
herniated disc in his neck and they need
to take care of that so that's a big
deal and that is a big surgery coming up